I want to completely change gears here
folks it was brought to my attention
just this morning a couple hours ago
that and this is absolutely true this is
not a joke that a show in China has
completely ripped off our opening show
sequence the sequence that we show at
the beginning of our program the
animated sequence this is real it's the
show called da Peng it's a show that
comes from China
someone made us aware of this we looked
into it and it blew my mind I want you
to look at a split screen of the da Peng
opening and my opening side-by-side this
is absurd
take a look at this look at this they
need they just exactly took and they
completely ripped off everything so who
by the way is Chinese for Dax Shepard
unbelievable yeah
[Music]
that's madness now to make matters worse
it's a really weird show this is an
actual clip from the show this is real
we're not making this up
I see they don't we don't work cheaters
don't want them like cheers well they're
gonna send up a boy one door in the
total okay here's what I want to say
four years now China's been ripping off
America with cheap knock-offs
right well China if you're gonna rip off
my show I think I should rip up their
show don't you
[Applause]
Sting's doesn't it I just wish that you
mean it probably needs in your face
[Applause]
[Music]
yes
[Applause]